the washburn fire began in yosemite
national park on thursday
officials say the fire threatens some
500 sequoia trees in an area called
mariposa grove and that includes the
famous grizzly giant it's some of the
oldest trees that there are there's
trees that are 2 000 years old they're
massive giants when you stand next to
them
as firefighters moved in some
1600 people at a nearby campground and
community were told to leave
so far the washburn fire has burned more
than 280 hectares
park officials say they could close more
of the national park if necessary it
looks pretty scary and we're going full
force on our suppression tactics
for now visitors are cautiously
proceeding with their vacations it's
definitely eerie
but it doesn't make me want to turn
around
i want to keep going
[Music]
sequoias have evolved to withstand fire
but they don't always escape
wildfires in the last two years have
destroyed nearly 15 thousand sequoias 20
percent of the 75 thousand estimated
trees found in the american west
so far park officials don't know when
the washburn fire will be brought under
control
rosalyn jordan al jazeera